alles weiter wie die hefte bundeskanzler
sehr geehrte damen und herren es ist
sehr schön dass sie sich zwischen
opposition und regierung so gut
verstehen dass sie zu einem kompromiss
gefunden haben aber uns liegen alle
diese anträge gar nicht vor haben wir
hier geschlafen oder am sie geschlafen
was ist hier eigentlich los legen sie
doch die anträge vor dass wir sie auch
hier vernünftig abstimmen können aber
zurück zum haushalt ist eine
haushaltsdebatte wenig hat herr merz
über den haushalt geredet aber diese
haushalt ist ein dokument der
abgehobenheit der realitätsverweigerung
und der ignoranz gegenüber dem zustand
des landes und seiner menschen
die regierungskoalition muss sich an die
welt zu retten die energieversorgung für
ein industrieland im alleingang neu zu
regeln und das klima in 50 oder 100
jahren zu regeln aber das eigene land
und seine menschen werden ruiniert
sie reden von zeitenwende aber sie
handeln nicht danach die kapseln sich in
ihrer ideologischen fantastereien ein
von klimaschutz energiewende
multikulturalismus diversität und
verweigern den blick auf die realität
deutschland steckt in einer
fundamentalen wirtschafts- finanz- und
staatskrise die alles bisher dagewesene
übertrifft
und dennoch
und dennoch geben sie das geld mit
vollen händen aus sie verteilen es in
alle welt klima milliarden für in den
hier
milliarden waffen milliarden für die
ukraine darf sie bleiben den
staatsapparat noch weiter auf sie
schaffen neue regierungsposten und
genehmigen sich großzügig noch mehr
stellen in den ministerien und
verwaltung für die eigenen bürger und
steuerzahler bleiben dagegen nur
trostpflaster und alibi politik die
deutschen zahlen mit die höchsten
steuern und abgaben der westlichen welt
sie bekommen dafür
miserable renten und einen zunehmenden
funktionsfähigen staat einen staat der
immer weniger in der lage ist seine
kernaufgaben wahrzunehmen die
aufrechterhaltung von
rechtsstaatlichkeit und öffentliche
ordnung die gewährleistung von innerer
und äußerer sicherheit der sich aber
immer dreister und über griffiger in das
privatleben der bürger einmischt sie
bevormundet und ihn dafür immer tiefer
in die tasche greift die krise in der
unser land steckt ist nicht vom himmel
gefallen sie ist politisch gemacht
inflation energieknappheit
explodierender energiepreise
gestörte lieferketten fachkräftemangel
und überlastete sozialkassen sind die
folge politischer fehlentscheidungen und
nein
sie können die verantwortung dafür nicht
allein auf putins angriffskrieg schieben
die ursachen liegen tiefer
die fatalen fehlentscheidungen wurden
früher getroffen und sie sind vor allem
in berlin und brüssel gefallen die
galoppierende inflation ist die quittung
für exzessive schulden machen und für
die geldschwemme und null zinspolitik
der europäischen zentralbank zur
subventionierung der euro hoch
schuldenstaaten 8 prozent inflation
heißt sparta
rücklagen und rentenansprüche sind nach
sechs jahren nur noch die hälfte wert
die reallöhne sinken als folge der
inflation fast 40 prozent der deutschen
wissen gar nicht mehr wie sie ihren
lebensunterhalt bestreiten sollen was
haben sie dazu eigentlich gesagt was
haben sie an lösung angeboten nichts
noch mehr bürokratische umverteilung ist
alles was diese ampel anzubieten hat
tank rabatt 9 euro ticket einmal zum
schüsse oder klima geld sind teure
bürokratische strohfeuer die nichts
bringen und ich muss es einfach so sagen
die nur ihre eigene unfähigkeit
kaschieren soll
steigende energiepreise heizen die
inflation weiter an und treiben
mittelstand und mittelschicht in die
farmer die deutsche energie krise hat
einer die energiewende kohle und atom
ausstieg zeitgleich flattr strom aus
wind und sonne als ersatz für eine
grundlastfähige günstige
energieversorgung wie wir sie einmal
hatten in diesem land und dazu als
neueste idee aus dem hause habeck die
beseitigung der erdgasinfrastruktur für
die wohnungs beheizung das konnte und
das kann nicht gut gehen sie aber
missbrauchen den krieg in der ukraine um
diesen irrweg noch zu beschleunigen noch
mehr geld dafür zu verbrennen und noch
mehr naturzerstörung durch monströse
windräder voranzutreiben die deutschen
energiekosten sind jetzt schon die
höchsten aller industrieländer ob mit
oder ohne ukraine krieg die energiewende
ist gescheitert und muss schleunigst
korrigiert werden und dazu muss die
erkenntnis kommen dass energie sanktion
gegen russland
kontraproduktiv sind und unserem land
mehr schaden zufügen als russland sehr
geehrte damen und herren und durch den
freiwilligen verzicht auf erdöl
lieferungen auf dem landweg das muss man
sich mal vorstellen
gefährden sie die treibstoffversorgung
im osten deutschlands um würden den
bürgern noch höhere energiepreise auf
den drohenden zusammenbruch der sozialen
sicherungssysteme vor dem der
bundesrechnungshof gerade in einem alarm
bericht gewarnt hat haben sie ebenfalls
keine antwort
unkontrollierte migration
löst weder fachkräftemangel noch
demografieprobleme und schon gar nicht
wenn man wahllos migration von
bildungsfernen und nicht integrierbare
aus fremden kulturkreisen zulässt und
sogar noch fördert dagegen sind in
vergangen ja
eine million menschen aus deutschland
ausgewandert nicht wenige sind
hochqualifizierte die für immer verloren
sind und dieser brain drain
diesem brain brain nehmen sie
achselzuckend hin und fahren fort mit
der negativen anreiz setzung für
qualifizierte arbeitnehmer so sieht die
politik aus und von den asyl zuwanderern
seit 2016 stichwort wir schaffen das
sind rund eine million immer noch eine
million zusätzliche kosten in unseren
sozialsystemen
was tun sie die funktionieren die hartz
iv
leistungen durch streichung der
sanktionsmöglichkeiten zum de facto
grundeinkommen um und sie wollen diese
leistung im nächsten schritt nicht nur
für ukrainische
kriegsflüchtlinge sondern für alle asyl
einwanderer öffnen das heißt sie
beschleunigen diesem trend und
qualifizierte einwanderung noch und wer
dagegen 45 jahre bei einem durchschnitts
bruttolohn von
24.000 euro im jahr gearbeitet hat
landet gerade auf einem hartz iv niveau
und sie tun nichts um diese
offensichtliche schieflage zu beseitigen
und das rentensystem auf eine tragfähige
grundlage zu stellen und das ist der
offenbarungseid für die
sozialdemokratisch geführte andere
begegnung
wir brauchen
tatsächlich eine echte zeitenwende in
der deutschen politik und das bedeutet
abschied vom ideologischen illusion und
konzentration der staatsaufgaben und
ausgaben auf das wesentliche es ist
richtig und überfällig den auf rüstungs
und
investitionsstau der bundeswehr mit
zusätzlichen ausgaben anzugehen
jahrzehntelang wurde die armee
vernachlässigt und
heruntergewirtschaftet dafür tragen sie
alle vor allem aber ihre partei herr
merz die verantwortung 16 jahre lang hat
die union kanzlerin und
verteidigungsminister gestellt da ist es
schon mehr als scheinheilig sich hier
als retter und beschützer der bundeswehr
auf zu spielen und den soli und
den soli wie merz dass sie eben
dargelegt hat und zu funktionieren als
sondersteuer zur reparatur der eigens
heruntergewirtschafteten bundeswehr das
ist ein schlag ins gesicht für alle
steuerzahler
die bezeichnung sondervermögen für
zusätzliche schulden ist ebenfalls ihre
für und warum nennen sie das
sondervermögen ist ein sonder schulden
und das wäre ehrlicher dass diese
ausgabe im grundgesetz verankert werden
soll um sie aus der allgemeinen
staatsverschuldung hinaus zu rechnen ist
ein unnötiger und unlauterer bilanztrick
und das wissen sie ganz genau und besser
werde es und daten steht die afd
überflüssige posten aus dem haushalt zu
streichen die sprechen hier von einem
rekordvolumen des haushaltes streichen
sie überflüssige posten und
konzentrieren sie die staatsausgaben auf
das wesentliche und niemand kann
behaupten dass dafür keine spielräume
vorhanden wären der staat hat den
deutschland nicht zu wenig geld sondern
zu viel das verstehen sich vielleicht
das konzept und ersetzt bei diesen
ausgaben die falschen prioritäten darum
geht es doch und der auf das vierfache
des volkes ohne haushalts
aufgeblasene etat des
gesundheitsministeriums
ist durch nichts zu rechtfertigen der
überforderte gesundheitsminister darf
also weiter milliarden nicht benötigter
impfdosen bestellen und anlasslose
massentest ung veranlassen und unser
land hat gerade wahrhaftig andere sorgen
als die neuauflage fakten freier
grundrechts einschränkungen und
rechtswidriger ins kampagnen
viel geld wieder ausgegeben für
zensurmaßnahmen meinungs- kontrolle da
sind sie ja spitzenreiter und dem
sogenannten kampf gegen rechts drängende
echte sicherheitsprobleme werden dagegen
herunter gespielt vor allem wenn es sich
um die importierte kriminalität handelt
deutschland braucht weder neue steuern
noch neue schulden um wieder auf die
beine zu kommen wir brauchen die
rückkehr zu soliden staatsfinanzen und
das erfordert mehr als folgenlose tweets
dieses bundesfinanzministers
stampfen wir lieber einige
lieblingsprojekte grüne und linke
ideologie und klientelpolitik ein dann
haben wir auch geld zur entlastung der
menschen und lassen wir den bürgern ihr
sauer verdientes geld in ihrem eigenen
portemonnaie dort ist es am besten
aufgehoben
geld wir den bürgerlichen und
unternehmerischen
der unternehmerischen freiheit
wieder vorrang statt bevormundung und
kontrollwahn liebe ampelkoalition und
kehren wir zurück zur realpolitik
setzen die interessen des eigenen landes
genau dahin wo sie hingehören und zwar
an die erste stelle ich bin da gibt es
[Applaus]